hamon comme un repos les nations unies
ont été créés pour empêcher qu'à
l'avenir des pays déclenché une nouvelle
guerre mondiale
en tant que pays neutre nous sommes la
deuxième vague de soldats irlandais est
renvoyé au congo oh [ __ ] une saloperie
de serpents l'emplacement de ce camp est
une fumisterie
on est totalement à découvert ils
n'oseront jamais s'attaquer à votre
compagnie vous n'avez jamais combattu
vous avez un plan juste une prière on
n'a pas besoin de plans
une attaque au sol
j'exige votre reddition si vous
continuez de nous attaquer on va
continuer de riposter vous rendez compte
que nous sommes au moins 20 fois plus
nombreux au bourg
laissez tomber
nous faut des renforts
l'enjeu des choses plus graves que vous
ne pouvez l'imaginer
les jeunes à [ __ ] des chances pour a
dites moi ce que je suis supposé frère
pendant tous un rôle à jouer dans
l'histoire
le vôtre c'est maintenant vous de jouer
elles sont à la gauche
m
vous
toulouse
non